i want to focus on positive coveted
stories uh so first you know one of the
places where there has been just the
worst sort of draconian lockdowns in the
entire world has been in australia
it's just been absolutely insane in
australia i mean police arresting people
for walking their dogs really crazy
stuff but people are stepping up they're
fighting back they're saying enough's
enough you don't own us just because
you're the government you work for us
that's what we have to remember look at
these lockdown protests in perth
australia
absolutely extraordinary what you're
seeing there we're just doing a little
b-roll here so i'm going to talk you
through it i mean
thousands and thousands of people those
are not right-wing maniacs those are not
evil people those are people who want to
live their lives as free citizens in the
western democracy that is known as
australia they don't want to live in a
giant
island prison
known as australia they want to live in
a free australia so pretty extraordinary
now note you are not going to see that
on cnn you might see a little something
about the previous story we just touched
on in wisconsin in australia because
they can't ignore it but why is it that
mainstream media never shows us when
thousands and thousands of people and
free democracies stand up could it be
that mainstream media is actually
working for the elites and whoever it is
that wants to keep you controlled and
quiet and scared and they don't want you
to realize that you have far more power
than you think if you just speak up you
might inspire somebody else to speak up
and next thing you know three people are
speaking up and then god forbid you got
four and yada yada yada suddenly you're
living as a free human being the way god
intended could that be
next up winsome sears who is the
incoming lieutenant governor of virginia
she will be the second in command under
glenn younkin she was on dana bash's cnn
show and i'm not very impressed with
this dana bash and dana bash i like
saying her name like that dana bash
asked winsome sears what her vaccination
status is and her answer was quite
spectacular
saying whether you are vaccinated do you
want to say now
as i said
america if it's nothing else it's about
liberty it's about being able to live
your life free from the government
telling you what to do and so we
understand this this thing about
slippery slopes the minute that i start
telling you about my vaccine status
we're going to be down the bottom of the
mountain trying to figure out how we got
there because now you want to know
what's in my dna you're going to want to
know this that and the other in in new
york you see we have people waiters
waiters asking people their vaccination
status and by the way do you know what
else they require a photo id to
determine if this vaccine card you're
presenting is really you
who are we fooling come on
let's say you get the vaccine go ahead
and get the vaccine if that's what you
want to do get the vaccine don't force
it on anybody else we know and by the
way media they're not telling us that
people are suffering as a result of
getting the vaccine uh there they have
all kinds of problems i understand it
might be the the minuscule but when
you're the one out of thirty thousand
that gets it it's important to you
i mean that's just a great answer right
there by winsome sears again the
lieutenant governor of virginia this is
a woman who will now be called a white
supremacist and an evil republican and
all of those things now as far as dana
bash
it's none of dana bash's
uh it's none of her business
sorry it's none of your business dana
bash whether winsome sears is vaccinated
she's completely correct this has
nothing to do with people's personal
decisions related to vaccines it has
everything to do with government
coercion do you not understand that dana
bash i understand that you dana bash and
the rest of your employees and friends
at cnn are a bunch of seals right so if
the government tells you to do things
especially if it's a government you like
in the case of joe biden then you'll
gladly do it i suspect dana bash that if
donald trump was still president and
demanding that everyone get vaccines
you'd be pushing against it because
donald trump bad guy joe biden good guy
very very simple in your simple black
and white world but her answer is
spectacular she also addresses that some
people have had adverse reactions i know
several people in my own life that have
had it and it simply is nobody's
business
what you do medically to
your self those are the people i'm
interested in spotlighting people who
say no no
it's none of your business you do
whatever you want
and stay out of my life because that's
the american spirit and that's what
we're going to push anyway i'm going to
show you two fouchy videos because it's
i'm just over him just
just try to imagine anyone watching this
this is him on his you know he does his
sunday press tour with his ridiculous
softball questions and his answers that
are completely meaningless at this point
so here's just two quick ones and if you
know anyone in your life that's still
listening to this person
might i recommend a full frontal
lobotomy fouchy one we would hope and
and this is something that we're looking
at very carefully that that third shot
with the mrna not only boosts you way up
but increases the durability so that you
will not necessarily need it every six
months or a year we're hoping it pushes
it out more if it doesn't and the data
show we do need it more often
then we'll do it
oh screw you i mean really i mean that
like what else do i have to say to this
guy now six months or a year and the
boosters it's gonna boost you a little
more and i think so i guess the vaccines
don't work fauci i guess you're an
anti-vaxxer right because when people
thought they were getting vaccinated it
was because they thought it was going to
stop them from getting or transmitting
kovid which neither is true when it
comes to these vaccines and finally more
from this ridiculous buffoon
i presume we have to be cautious during
thanksgiving you talked about christmas
protection with those boosters but
quickly if you will thanksgiving
well if you're a booster i mean you see
if you're if you're vaccinated and
hopefully you'll be boosted too and your
family is you can enjoy a typical
thanksgiving meal thanksgiving holiday
with your family there's no reason not
to do that the thing we are concerned
about is the people who are not
vaccinated because what they're doing is
they're the major source
of the dynamics of the infection in the
community and the higher the level
of dynamics of infection the more
everyone is at risk but if you're
vaccinated you look at the data martha
it's absolutely clear the likelihood of
getting infected getting hospitalized or
dying if you're vaccinated versus
non-vaccinated weighs very very heavily
in the protection of people who are
vaccinated
enough with this clown again i'm only
showing you this to completely mock him
like not so that you listen to him but
you shouldn't listen to me either
actually you should listen to your own
doctor and make some choices for
yourself but he's just the dynamics of
the infection you know what i'm having
people over for thanksgiving family
members and friends i actually don't
know if they're all vaccinated i don't
care if you believe the vaccinations
work then you should not care if someone
else gets vaccinated and if you think
that this ridiculous buffoon clown two
years after two weeks to flatten the
curve deserves your attention or your
respect i don't know what to say to you
i actually i'm out of human words i feel
like joe biden being asked a basic
question i got nothing